hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast a neo virus-like Starla
exhibited by a positive SSRN a Fire's
hosted in an unrelated D s RNA virus
taxonomic and evolutionary
considerations presented by Nobuhiro
Suzuki professor Institute of plant
science and resources at Oakley online
university I am Marjorie turrets of lab
foods and I'll be your moderator for
today's event we are delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by libraries laberd's is a
leading scientific social networking
website and producer of educational
virtual events and webinars before we
begin I would like to remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
and anytime you want during the
presentation just click on the green Q&A
button located in the lower left of the
presentation window and type your
question into the box that appears on
the screen well answer as many questions
as we have time for at the end of the
presentation also please notice that you
will be viewing the presentation in the
slide window to enlarge the window just
click on the screen icon located on the
lower right if you not trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation please click on
the support button at the top right of
the presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know that you are
having a problem this presentation is
educational and that's offers continuing
education credits please click on the
button in the bottom left corner and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
Nobuhiro Suzuki I will now turn the
presentation over to him
thank you much for your great
introduction of myself my name is Dane
Nobuhiro Suzuki from the Institute of
plant science and resources Okayama
University my talk is composed of two
parts the first one is introduction of
fungal biases particularly infecting
filamentous fungi to new and in the
second part that is the main part of my
talk or presentation I try to convince
you of new virus lifestyle or unique
virus virus interactions or Enterprise
in the white root rot fungus which is
plant pathogenic fungus so first this
size shows you where I'm from where I am
now so I'm based in krasiki City Okayama
Prefecture which is located west roughly
200 kilometers west of shelter the
distance is just one hour wide by bullet
train from Kyoto so Tracy city is famous
for its historical view shown here the
city tried to preserve old-fashioned
buildings built in aero or 180 euros and
this city is famous for denim or jeans
so our Institute shown here is in the
downtown of the city I'm now in I'm now
in this building and shown here
but this institute is over 100 years old
okay back to your science so first our
let me introduce fungal viruses I'm sure
most people or most audience is
unfamiliar with policies infecting fungi
so it's believed that over one point
million species fungal species in the go
and not all fungi shown here are tested
for a virus infection that some were
tested previously and they show that a
few percent to over 90 percent of field
effects of each moment species tested
virus infected in other words each
fungal species has their own virus world
with great diversity among 1.5 million
informant species only a limited number
of fungi or pathogenic to human over
plants so for about 50 fungal species
are known to us to be human of genic and
roughly pampered on fungal species our
plant pathogenic exemplified rice blast
or chestnut blight or powdery mildew
fungus shown here you may wonder why we
studied fungal biases very minor area of
biology
so my laboratory has been working on
fungal biases for many years for a few
reasons
and so here these are not all but some
so final bias studies can contribute to
understand bias diversity in fact the
last decade
we have shown that their new bias
families in Tanja examples include
Megatron appeared a booty burn at midday
and core ability so such studies lead to
discoveries of new virus structures
particle structures and gene expression
strategies for Advanced Studies also
contribute to understanding of viral
replication and symptom expression and
her positive impact on other biology
like new chaotic biology or plant
biology for example our plunger have
like other new carriers and biodefense
responses so far to defense mechanisms
are known one its RNA I Aragon silencing
which is conserved across eukaryotic
organisms
the other one is vegetative
incompatibility which works at the
population level so studies it for such
topics can stimulate
the similar areas of other biologists
like plant biology or eukaryotic animal
biology and nasty big fans are
pathogenic to parents or crops or
chattels or animals biases infecting
them may be able to be used as
biological control agents as
demonstrated in hyper balances which can
successfully control just that black
fungus in Europe and new rats and other
examples include white meat rot a bio
control which is tested in Japan and
also Sclerotinia slytherin in China
these are still experimental but
promising approach for control of plant
fungal disease so let me remind you of
general features of fungal viruses
farmer biases are different from plant
or animal viruses this slide summarizes
the difference and general properties of
them saga biases have no X Australian
root for entry so very different from
other policies and their transmission is
limited to vertical pierce ports and
horizontal linear - so let me explain a
little bit more about horizontal
transmission because I touch this later
stage of my talk
so as you know filamentous fungus can
make network by fusing one Masseria
mycelium to another as shown here which
is called anastomosis or hyper fusion by
doing this site plasmic material of one
- can move from one party to another
that included policies and all an era
but this - fusion occur only between are
they stated being comfortable my Syria
or Collins so if the two colonies are
comfortable as shown here virus shown by
genie press can be moved from one
impacted colony to visually uninfected
colonies shown here so this side was
Region II virus free shown by T - so
this virus transmission occurs in
comfortable combinations
however if two colonies are physically
incapable within one single species
virus can't move from one side to
another because after the hyford contact
programmed cell death occurred which
hampers virus transmission shown here so
the phenotype of two colonies
stay the same with that virus
transmission okay
so back to general features from from
your biases they showed persistent
infection so they are from advises
persist eternally basically and most
fungal viruses have TS double-stranded
RNA genomes okay and some of summer
prices form rigid particles but others
not so this point is very different from
other usual biases infecting animal or
plant and certain cell movement is
possible the acceptable spores which
connect once out another through
receptive sports even neutral I can move
so in the second part this is the main
topic of today's presentation I try to
convince your new virus lifestyle shown
by to fungal biases okay viruses can be
defined as shown here probably a very
simple way viruses are infectious
nanoparticles encasing genomic nucleic
acids
however the past two decades huge our
great discoveries curve which challenged
these virus rules and concepts one of
them is Katsidis viruses which are
unable to form our widget particles as I
mentioned for foreign policies in my
previous slide
ii went giant DNA viruses i can show you
these exceptional viruses of the capsid
responses are mostly found in fungi
exemplifying hypo virus and nano virus
and Ebola viruses they don't make
typical virus particles like spherical
particles but instead their genomes are
encased in host derived vesicles shown
here this is is proposed for hyper
viruses the second biases that challenge
virus woods are giant DNA viruses these
policies exceed some bacteria in the
sides of genome and particles these
fighters heads over are as we see here
point 5 micrometer in size and their
genome it's over 1.2 megabytes bear and
a very samples are shown here like
Pandora vials and petabytes so these are
examples challenging the bias moods the
past five years we had also chanced to
discover such bias which shows new virus
lifestyle which is a captured bass
positive-sense single-stranded RNA virus
hosted by an unrelated double standard
RNA bites so this relation is complex
but
beside the slates but the relationship
of the three main viral players now the
new [ __ ] virus and the yellow curry
violence if you are Japanese you can
readily know the relationship when you
can guess but for those of you who have
known Japanese yada Russia literally
means in Japanese landlord or room owner
okay
while the other curry means following
the rule to say or hermit crab
biologically so you may be able to guess
now the relationship between the two
biases so let me explain the new
lifestyle of these viruses so where
these viruses are fund is the one of the
unplanned pathogenic fungi
Rossellini anecca tricks which is
notorious because this fungus is
distracted and spreading in the soil in
the form of my failure and this fungus
kill the host tree and this is an
example one of the examples of disease
tree cherry tree almost dying and
sometimes this fungus destroy the entire
water and this fungus has a wide host
range over four hundred
our plant species to control this
disease from at spore chemicals and
shown here 50 to 200 meter per tree so
it's very time and labor constant so in
the banking language dr. BOTS model he
proposed fire control and one form of
bio control using viruses infecting
pathogenic fungus so he and his team
collected over 1,000 field I set some of
this furnace from all over Japan to to
find pious waste pile control a
potential which means the virus should
be able to reduce the rest of the host
fungus to use other biological control
so the results are shown here the day
found that 20% of collected function
health viruses Singley debris or
treatment which means co-infection with
more than one fight so we joined this
project in 2009 we are given one of the
are one of such pilot suited for in
strength so in this side so the the
fungal strains 10:32 and shown here this
field isolate is reduced in growth rate
shown here and also this is hyper
Darrell in other words this fungus knows
the ability to weaken the host apple
tree I can show you an item and
importantly this fungus has a few and
these are renamed ants showing here
which could be a patina of viruses so we
took our laboratory took a closer look
at this fungal strength
10:32 first we purified dillion's
from that strain and we tested it using
an electron microscope shown here the
fraction purify diffraction has one type
of particles which is 40 nanometer in
diameter spinnaker particles and this
purified fraction had three and a
serenade shown here and this fraction
has one single protein dead when
examined by us in stage protein gel and
then we sequenced this these three MDS
RNA elements by using conditional vs RNA
sequencing method so the largest one was
turned out to be the genome of a deist
RNA virus we named it yonder mushi virus
won the genome science was almost 9 KD
ways to open reading frame the second
three proximal open reading frame to
encodes RNA dependent RNA polymerase
which is the hallmark of RNA viruses so
responsible for emeritus replicas the
second one the very faint them well
shown to be a defective RNA of yada new
she fires the first one so this Phi R
disappears RNA nuts earlier Pietschmann
doesn't affect it which is unable to
replicate without helper virus you'll
miss fights the third one the the tick
Bank was shown to be the genome of
another bias another Curie bias which
has positive-sense single-stranded RNA
genome the site is 6.3 KB I'm showing
here but please remember this virus
fraction has one type of virus and one
type probably one protein and and the
phylogeny of two biases are shown here
the first bonus is RNA virus adenovirus
cluster with other antennas RNA viruses
shown here where earth young locally
bias shows phylogenetic affinity -
carisi biases that includes notorious
sample neural biases pathogenic to human
are consumed very near sometimes
so two viruses the other mission the
other calibers totally different by the
genetically so back to the protein
component of ten thirty treat by us
fraction as I mentioned earlier this
fraction has only one single band we
analyzed this protein band by two
approaches one is peptide massive
imprinting and the other one is five
also and terminal sequencing so this
protein was mapped to G prime a portion
of open reading frame one organ which
buyers should hear I'm starting at this
place but importantly no peptide
fragments who are mapped to other open
reading frame including the other
carbines so if you are a biologist you
may predict this we are denoted by the
CP trans encapsulate Adhikari box so we
tested this hypothesis using
immunoprecipitation first we prepared
and only against recombinant adenovirus
CP and the news that for
immunoprecipitation of sorry 10:32
Delian fractions so please record here
the input is shown here 10:32 diría so
we are anti yard anusha piracy he can
precipitate some fractions portion
villians that precipitates contain the
Adhikari virus RNA and of course we are
to miss apparently as shown here and
also yada yada lucify the CP and body of
course can pivot the revolution by the
CP as expected but important point here
is the other Kariba this RNA is also
immunoprecipitate so this result
indicate that you know don't notify the
CP happy I'm capsulated Yahoo color bias
RNA actually not only yellow curry bias
RNA but also radically virus algae RP
I'm good here is encased by a
diversified CP which was tested by
Western blot analysis using yellow curry
buyers of yuppie antibody for this
experiment we prepare to theorem
fractions one is original 1032 until
infraction
the other one is isogenic fungal strains
563 in fact do its
yard Alicia virus one alone I'd
explained this how we obtain this viral
strain over former strength later
so anyway and these video fractions were
subjected to Western and the results
show here only doubly infected 10:32
provided two bands one is 100 Kb
the second ones smaller band 40k yay
back so this results showing that our
DLP included by radically bias one is
also encapsulated in trans by Anusha
virus CP so you may wonder whether on
your own carry virus is dependent on the
admission bias in other words you had a
new Shiva I'm sorry yeah no Kali virus
regards its viability on the hardness
virus to test this
Witek transfection protocol shown here
this is how we artificially introduced
or knock you right for now a host first
we prepare single-cell protoplasts from
virus free my Syria as shown here by the
braiding cell wall and in the presence
of p EG polyethylene glycol and calcium
ions dillion's are mixed with not only
Didion's also we can introduce RNA or
DNA using the same method billions are
introduced into still across this stage
not all broadcasts are infected with the
fires but during regeneration of my
syria the pious can systemically
in fact the entire column this is how we
are looking at from the host using not
bus so the result regard is shown here
we analyzed many transfected some of
them are shown in this jar
but to summarize the result the
transparency were grouped into four
threads shown here the first group
carries only the other machine virus
second one I had the Machine and the
Machine defective RNA third one needs
the other mushi and the other coil the
false one is the same as additional ten
thirty two thousand species having three
near serenades the other machine and the
initiative active and yellow curry virus
but importantly no yellow curry by a
single infection was observed so this
means yellow curry virus probably
depends its viability on Yadav misfires
to further confirm this conclusion we
took Florence CNA approach we prepare
the French yellow curry virus 1c denied
flanked by two my friends
hammerhead type and hepatitis Delta
minus ribozyme the idea here is in
transformers with this construct
authentic radically bias RNA are made in
transformed cells so if the other career
iris is dependent on Russia virus only
in the presence of the eternal virus
infection Jana Corrie virus can
replicate to test this we took
co-culture method on PDA synthetic
plates
so we not to fungal colonies peels in
one single plate
one side is inoculated with the other
curry by the seed and a transformed the
second column needs inoculated here with
the initial virus single infected as I
showed you before we got after
transfection now billions singing
transparence one of the our prototypes
so if they huge and exchange cytoplasmic
materials you have to Khalid virus may
be able to replicate after receiving the
other Misha bites so the the results are
shown here so this side shows before
call culture and right hand side
students African culture so K and M and
denotes transformants with the Adhikari
and in fact that with the other machine
a No so before call culture the Adhikari
- savanna transformants can produce
transcripts which are produced in
nuclear as expected and detectable by
rt-pcr but no RDS RNA which is
replicated form of an Ocala virus while
you have initial balance transformer can
produce PS RNA but of course not
radically virus transcript and after
culturing very interestingly the an
Ocala bias now
able to replicate their peers other
nations here together whilst not
ownership iris from application shown
here so only in the presence of your
ownership iris the other career virus
can replicate so this result clearly
indicate the other calibers runs on the
other Musa files for liability okay but
still we don't know yet whether
radically virus newest Yahoo clarifiers
our net dependent RNA primers or
replicas or the other mushi virus
replicates so to test this we took
advantage of reverse genetics because we
now have seed in an infectious crown of
the other new Shiva
so another curry buddies so we you take
it you know Kali by the pseudonym motifs
GDD shown here DVD motif is the
catalytic motif responsible for RNA
synthesis and we made other DVD motif by
substitution
I mentioned I forgot to mention m3
mutant has Activision so now GED become
Gd and second key idea
Newton DVD was changed to G ad and we
also made
Newton's and 3 prime UTR
okay we use these friends constructs for
transformation and we did the same way
as the previous style so the result is
shown here
we checked replication contention and
gdt mutants were no longer able to
replicate while three prime UTR mutants
can replicate so this result shows that
all the ERP encoded biological virus is
transitions in chap stated by a Tanisha
pie recipe and is functional in the
Adhikari biased arguments entities from
this result you may wonder what over
whether in a local virus has impact on
Russia but the answer is yes we compare
your donor stylist content or
accumulation in the presence or absence
of yellow curry buyers so please compare
the other misha buyers the top esra need
and are here in in the presence of
yellow curry bar as shown here or
absence of yellow curry buyers this gel
or is designed to compare our
quantitatively and I compared against
ribosomal RNA so this RNA is total RNA
from an infected fungal host so please
compare the interns field we are Anisha
Paris it's evident that Janusz a virus
accumulations enhanced in the presence
of your caliber
so you have encoded by us benefits to
the application of the antivirus so the
relationship between the two balances or
mutualistic not commensal so we have
proposed the replication cycle a model
full replication cycle or the two biases
based on the results I explained to you
so in other news virus is an independent
DSL in a palace so like other dear son
an empire sees the other misha palace
encapsulate their own in a positive
sense and within the particle the RNA is
replicated and double strand RNA
encasing captive can now serve as
transcription place to produce messenger
RNAs for translation of Sydney and sepia
the appeal the other color balance on
the other hand hijacks the CP of your
ownership Alice and transmute up state
not only RNA of other qualifiers but
also in the other calibers are DRP to
replicate and to transcribe Audrina so
you have the qualifiers behave like GS
RNA virus as if it weren't necessarily
but although its genome is positive
sense RNA it's a little bit complex tone
still we don't know yet so here here are
some open questions showing here we must
demonstrate yellow curry virus
replicates in the endogenous virus has a
capsule to this end we took the
advantage of yellow curry virus infected
see denied to sho Yano Kaori virus ldrp
is used for the synthesis of the auto
caliber Sunday I've shown before but
still we have performed at least two
experiments one is to know purified
health capsids
can serve as replication site this is
kind of biological approach the second
experiment is to determine an admission
by the CP over expresses with that the
other miss virus infection can support
in an Ocala virus replication this is a
genetic approach other open questions
include the other carried by a snake
viruses are found in other fragile just
last year an Italian group and also a
Japanese group report similar sequences
of venom what it is like - and volume
poor Michael - tree this pile of
sequence it's similar to the other
columns but we don't know yet whether
parkland policies
defaming can support these other
collector policies and in the case for
yard okarian regard these parts
and we are also run interested in
evolution Coronado Calabasas
because we believe any buyers won't be
independent unlike like human being but
at the moment we are ownership alice is
dependent virus so what was previous
form in future form or colonizers let me
try our premature hypothesis for the
evolution of Calabasas I'm not home
together but you're also interested in
where does virus comes from and what it
is now and where it is going so the
oldest in our model based on previous
research on other policies and our
results we got in our lab so we believe
ancestral colony like virus was the
progenitor virus of caravans judged from
its phylogenetic relations committee
virus and the projector bias might have
lost the CD gene and the encountered
neutralist partner with this RNA genome
so the present form of the other Chi
it's explained by myself up to here
yellow curry virus is dependent virus
depend on your Denisha virus and
capsiplex dials so in in the future
yeah the cutting bias may have two
possibilities one is as an independent
chats with us post-its and
single-stranded RNA now the qualifiers
may become like present extent chat
cedras foreign policies that utilize
host remembering as the replication site
just like hyper viruses or not other
viruses the second possibility is
radically bias and become food threat
and D s RNA virus after acquiring the
CPG from the partner your the mission
pilot snack pilot so these two
possibilities and what we are thinking
now so this is I think the last side to
the acknowledgement some of you may be
confused by other US policies was some
viral agent with yellow curry virus this
table shows the mister of senior policy
source of viral agent here is yellow
curry virus and this virus has
positive-sense single-stranded RNA but
doesn't include capsid cooking certain
the RNA strands in chop see capsulated
by the partner virus yet initialize
so the other color - now is not
autonomously replicating but
this virus includes Allen and pollen
minutes let me explain other some of the
other example like vampires this is
plant virus this has also
single-stranded RNA virus that doesn't
include like other calibers no capsid
protein so interpretation depends on the
popular beauty virus so very similar in
this sense but this virus can replicate
autonomously and in codes are many
parameters so without partner this virus
can systemically in fact plant so this
point is very different from the other
calibers and if you are interested in
animal viruses I can show you the
difference between hepatitis tell Tobias
and yellow carry virus hepatitis tell
Tobias has circular negative sense RNA
genome and doesn't include major capsid
protein so trans in capsid capsulated by
hepatitis B virus this virus does encode
RNA polymerase so in this palace news is
host and DNA dependent RNA polymerase so
this virus is not able to replicate
autonomously
who is that hepatitis B virus so now you
see yellow curry virus is totally
different from other policies or some
viral agents I hope I can
from this year of the new viral
lifestyle exhibited by the other carrot
virus and yada Misha virus to wrap up my
talk I'll bacterial pink now members are
shown here
doctors condo and rossano
these two people were involved directly
involved in the results I explained to
you today and fungal strains are
provided by satyr Kolkata Matsu and
other collaborators are highly
appreciated thank you so much for your
patient I hope you understand my talk
thank you doctor Nabu Heroes is acute
for that informative presentation
unfortunately it looks like we are out
of time however if you do have questions
you'd like to ask you might click on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window type your
questions into the box that appears on
your screen and click on the send button
he will answer as many of the questions
as he it's time for via email I would
like to once again thank dr. Nova here
is Suzuki for his presentation I would
also like to thank lab boots for making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go I want to let everyone know
that today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through December
2017 you will receive an email from
labyrinth letting you know when this
webcast will be available for replay
please share that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
blog bet that's all for now thank you
for joining us and we hope to see you
again soon goodbye